okay people joining the livestream this
is one of an infinite series of internal
meetings to do with language
completeness and consistency and we've
got a variety of topics for today so
let's start with the rest $1 script file
name right so there was some meeting CSE
meeting that uses some calendar snafu I
wasn't I missed and so I got the notes
from it and and also had a chat with
Garret and it wasn't entirely clear to
me what was decided so I'm here taking
my my interpretation of what this should
be
and getting clarification on that okay
what do we think this this is okay so
right so you you came up with this name
dollar evaluation source file which
sounds like a reasonable thing and and
we already have dollar valuation cloud
object one thing it's not it's not a
documented symbol and it's I don't see
it in the system context and so okay I
mean what it would mean if it existed
why did not exist in my belt you need to
be logged into the cloud for it to exist
maybe huh okay I don't know why not that
is the most ugly example what on earth
is that that's ridiculously ugly sushma
can you try to get that fixed
why is it saying read list that is the
that's the code and the loud deploy yeah
I don't know why but why is it why does
one want to do that I mean why isn't it
just why is it saying weedless that the
hackers realest got to do with it well I
presume that it's showing that you can
use it as if it were any other kind of
file or similar object right so you're
gonna get the list of bytes that are at
the code of the API function or or lies
the IC IC has read the list non-binary
read list but that's a very weird object
I mean yeah I'm not I'm not saying that
it's an easy to understand example I'm
just sick of the crazy example did
anybody know who where this example came
from okay
Sushma can you try to get this example
fixed okay do you agree that this is a
reasonable construct this evaluation
cloud object thing although it should
presumably refer to this dollar
evaluation source file which is exactly
and script file name is not a thing it's
just a valuation source file an
evaluation cloud object oh yes so so
well neither dollar evaluation source
file nor dollar script file name are
things that was a proposal now the
dollar script file name was the working
name okay which we are proposing to
change the dollar valuation source file
right but I think there's also the
argument that that kind of exists
already as dollar input file name it's
right then I claim it does not and and
in particular I mean I think the first
bullet point is is a big difference
between it has one value to an
evaluation yes what is input file name
what what does input file name have when
input file name is the
name of the file currently being gated
by get so if you have a get and you you
know then inside the file you are
getting it'll be the value of that it
will be that file name and then if you
then get another file inside of that it
will change to that file name okay so
what is evaluation source file it is the
name where of the file where the
evaluation originated so if you have a
yeah I understand that makes perfect
sense so in a front end is that always
going to be the same as valuation book
probably so yeah what is it for a cloud
deployed thing right so I guess the
question is what do we mean by well I
guess a cloud deployed thing there I'm
not sure so if you if you have a Wolfram
script and you're evaluating it with ash
cloud then it shoulders where you write
it's the name of the script on your
local computer that you typed in right
now if you have for example if you do a
cloud evaluate what is it right this is
going to say nothing I assume probably
yeah it just doesn't know string though
right
okay so cloud evaluate of dollar
evaluation source file well I guess well
well well I guess the question is I mean
that evaluation I mean assuming that was
a safe notebook and not an unsafe it
probably wants to be the evaluation
notebook
of that which I don't even think that
the cloud knows right now
exactly Oh to be metadata that was
passed through just like a user agent
string is passed through some extent
Skerritt it you understand what I'm
saying here hey think so yeah I mean
it's a fair amount of trouble to do that
for something whose functionality is not
obvious to me right the correct thing is
go ahead I was gonna say it's gonna
require a change to the implementation
of cloud evaluate it's gonna require a
change to a bunch of stuff you know if
you want to have the first one passed
through no matter what path that's
taking you know from a notebook to the
cloud to you know some gets to well
there may be some mechanism with
persistent value that would allow this
to work easily yeah maybe right so I
think I mean I think yeah I'm not sure
what happens with a cloud evaluate but I
think I mean I think the set of changes
on desktop is pretty small basically
Colonel - script needs to learn about
this wolf from script needs to know to
set this and we need some code that if
we're connected to a front-end and we're
in a safe notebook then it's equal so
listen why don't we Commission you a tie
to go track down the details of this and
say to happen for the cloud all right
and I'm feeling it my suggestion is to
use the persistent value mechanism but
to treat it like another piece of user
metadata however it will be nice to have
some use cases where we care about this
in the cloud mm-hmm okay
there's nothing applicable so you're
you're in an unsafe notebook then this
should be the symbol done or I think so
is that consistent with what we're doing
for these other things I mean I don't
know what that is there let's see what
that one is there
I have a bad feeling it's a null string
oh that's weird
that's crazy it's not I mean it's not
crazy if you if you're thinking about it
from you know you have a uniform of data
types right yeah I understand but I
think that should instead be dollar
input file if there isn't one should be
none not a null string but again can you
check for consistency for other things
like that
yeah okay that behaviour documented the
four dollar info file name yes weird
does it offer any insight into why boy
well it's even a fairly recent vintage
2010
I'm surprised we did it that way well
maybe this was a rename oh yeah from
dollar input this is the behavior of
dollar input that's a little bit more
ancient 1991 yes uhm know why the
spacing is wrong there between the ears
and the double quote but that's a
different issue all right let's move on
updates to icon eyes so in other words I
would prefer none but we should
investigate whether that's feasible okay
okay
updates to icon eyes so what are we
saying here so I think the updates are
only in the prototype build so it's this
uh let me get a prototype build and my
changes haven't gone through graphic
design yet but Billy is here okay does
anybody know why we're having trouble
with the product our builds with the
Sign In
I wasn't aware that we were um I've seen
this problem for like a week or so okay
okay so I do this and and I can eyes
blob what's that
there you go Micah nice as opposed to D
icon eyes oh that's cool right here so
if I if I do that and I say icon eyes
that's cool
okay now if I say one two three four
whatever and I select that and I press
control shift I doesn't work but you're
saying that will be so in the Edit menu
is so in the main edit menu is it do you
have an entry for it you don't
why don't you well maybe I don't have
them recent enough build okay although I
do have yesterday
oh it's probably because I added it to
the does wolf and desktop has its own
menu set up file that's probably what it
is oh yeah so it probably worked it
works for me and in in Mathematica okay
I can try that if you want this looks
quite magnificent I mean the what was it
what are we looking to comment on here
it looks good to me
okay are you happy with the UH nikon
eyes being only exposed when you open up
the thing when you expand to get the
information are you at all happy with
the graphic design looks good let's look
at that let's look at them
um okay so first of all here the hope is
that in there we have a good that the
up-arrow is control shift I that's kind
of magnificent yeah okay right then you
can use the same shortcut to uh nikon
eyes it without opening it up so if you
select that and shift control eye then
it should it's really quite nice this is
really quite nice I guess my only issue
with this icon ization thing is I'm not
totally convinced about this pre icon
here you know now unlike on eyes I mean
the graphic design is not horrible I
don't know what that that I mean the
fact that there's some kind of hello II
think there is is not terrible I don't
know if Billy has a comment about how to
make it better but you know we got three
icons running around here we got that
pre icon we got the plus thing we got
this guy I know we talked about removing
the top left icon and swapping it out
with the plus minus and possibly doing a
new plus minus but that was a long time
ago maybe opinions have changed you know
in a perfect world I wouldn't have the
things say list in a perfect world I
would have something which is more like
a you know brace dot dot in the actual
text rather than the icon form and III
don't think this icon has such does us a
lot of good I know we've got a diversity
how many we have like five different
icons there right I think it's more like
nine but the more useful thing to see
would be this is a list dot dot dot
right or this is and you know F of dot
dot dot whatever it is
right and then to see some nice elegant
plus you know but again I don't think
the plus y and then the question is
whether that should go there I wonder
whether on hover why don't we why don't
we prompt for the keyboard shortcut on
hover as well see on hover here we could
even if we're closed right we could
prompt for that shortcut get what I'm
saying the shortcut that only works when
the thing is selected you want to
advertise it in a tooltip you know
you're saying that's crazy
no I'm trying to make sure I understand
your suggestion I think is that I will
say that that's crazy I don't think it's
crazy but it will potentially confuse
people yes well okay right I'm and of
course recognizer has the two argument
form where you give it a name label yes
fine
I think the iconography is too busy too
fussy yeah so you know I think we should
try to go towards having a single icon
and also having that plus not be the
weird gray thing on top of the blue but
something which more blends with the
blue because I just don't think it's
that important to plus to be giving
except for the UH nikon eyes and if it
was possible to give a you know even in
this closed form
to give something that is some kind of
hourly thing like this that you could
click even in closed form to uh nikon
eyes and if the hover thing gave you
some information about you know click
that to uh nikon eyes you get to get
what I'm saying mm-hmm
I have must say I would prefer to use
the word expand to the word uh Nikon
eyes um by the way we've got a bunch of
buzzing on the phone which make really
great to not have so the the menu items
do follow the uncomment metaphor which I
don't think is bad you have the menu
item it's pretty clear what you mean
when you see unshaken eyes but I think
in this case and what I'd like to see in
Billy this would be for you is a less
fussy version of this where we're
emphasizing instead of giving lists
which i think is obscure giving
something which is more like a textual
you know brace dot dot type thing that
makes sense to people the list of can we
see the list please of what the actual
current icons are the so-called nine
icons probably if you go to the ref page
most of them must show up in examples
but I guess I don't I'm not entirely
clear on what your suggestion is and and
also how it interacts with when you give
it a label I'm not sure about that
either with the label part of it ok so
look I've got several comments first of
all I think the gray plus on the blue
background is pretty ugly that's my
first point my second point is it would
be nice to have a one-step deionised an
icon eyes at the top level here third I
don't think this initial icon is adding
anything
fourth I don't like seeing lists that I
think that's obscure I would much prefer
to see something which is kind of the
way a human might might say it's a grace
thing with a bunch of stuff inside which
is kind of what that icon sets do great
so you're saying so basically you're
saying if for for a small list of things
we have a special right we have braced
ellipses brace and you know whatever are
the four other things and anything else
its head open bracket args I'm thinking
yeah I mean look I think that if we
could get something in here that says a
brace and indicates with a little
superscript n here or some such other
thing if it can be made obvious that
it's ten items that will be great
that gives you the maximum information
and so there's an indication of of what
it is but again it will be useful to see
what the complete list of those icons is
what I did just email okay the old the
the list of the current icons as well as
some alternates for the plus C I think
okay so we're really wanting two
different actions there we're wanting
the plus to see more detail about the
icon form if indeed we care about that
more detail you know is that all the
detail we have the head the length of
byte count pretty much maybe a
mouse-over maybe it should just give
that on the mouse over and not have an
expander that would mean there's no way
to copy that but maybe that's okay
company won't copy the content of you
know that one 84 in the bike count
I think we do the tooltips and you don't
have that but I can't say I've ever
really wanted to copy out those things I
think unlike in a summary box where I
actually you know for actual proper
summary boxes where I have wanted to
copy out specific pieces of information
I don't think I've ever particularly
wanted these pieces of information yes I
agree so okay so listen what I propose
is we try to simplify this we've got two
items
you know like with a string here I don't
see why we shouldn't just have something
which is basically string dot dots
whoops
string it's kind of unlovely that that
doesn't term correctly smart quote
itself but that was a different issue
yeah I just think these things are
unnecessarily cutesy I don't know what
we do with data set here right so with
right so right now with arrays right we
give rather than the length we give the
dimensions yes I mean it will be
magnificent if we were able to give look
I just think maybe we should just have
these icons but have them instead of the
word array string Association etc data
set we should make these richer icons
which can contain things that say things
like you know brace brace three by three
by fifty six or whatever something which
which can have a nice textual form there
and gives the information and what is
this
are you proposing what are you showing
them I'm showing an institute of H okay
is that all of them yes okay
so I just don't believe in let's give
the head thing I think it's ugly and I
think it's hard for people to understand
I think we should I think we should try
and custom make a you know a typeset
form for each of them like a string we
understand what it is I mean if we were
able to write bla bla characters above
it great that will be magnificent get
what I'm saying hey mister I said we
should write such and such a number of
characters on top there I don't think I
can necessarily mock it up here very
easily I mean here something like this
and then here we would put see if I can
make this work um control seven maybe
yeah that's what I was going to try
that's sensible I don't think that's
obviously stupid something like that
seems random flex well and the word
characters long okay it looks complex
but would it would it would it be enough
to just say two three four five
surrounded by what is that background
noise could we please you know set
things that we don't have that what what
does it do in the case of a too big
input I'm too big output for example
that has a pattern there right so if I
say something like uses a variant of
short and uses a custom skeleton display
that looks like this see that's nice
what that's doing I mean in other words
if what we could get was something which
is just that you get what I'm saying
right with quotes or braces or s of yes
it's very clear what that was I like
that idea to do that okay use the same
form I also wonder whether we should
make the blue of the icon eyes somehow
agree with the blue of the two big
output making sense Billy understand I'm
saying yeah we did we can match that
let's try it I'm not sure if it makes
sense we might want to change this one
as well but they seem like the same kind
of thing let's try to match that lozenge
thing let's try to if we have an array I
think we should do a dot dot dot I think
we can do a brace hump how to do that
anybody got an idea if we have a three
by seven thirty by seventy array I think
if we just did that
honestly we could just have the lozenge
without the braces and say 30 by 70 and
people would know what it was I'm making
sense I think so that would work for
data set also probably um for an image
what do we want to do that an image goes
to the fall-through case currently an
image gets no special consideration
currently and neither does graphics or
gray so it just says image then correct
right because I mean how often do you
actually want to convert an image to
like a nice yeah because you just make
the image small right right
fair enough okay I think we've got a
pause here so then then the plus goes
away it's just to hover and what is it
there instead of the plus is a expand me
button makes sense
mm-hmm yep and we need to talk to the
cloud folk about this to make sense yep
okay
on what that's very good all right
should we go on yep right all right so
so this is was a discussion that's well
started with the bug report and then L
kernel and then Lou and this giant
thread that I haven't read I don't think
it's a giant thread no but it was a
thread with some back and forth between
me and tally and and like a standing
made a couple of comments okay all right
so what's the idea here so right so the
idea is right so right so there are a
couple of problems well one of which is
that the
basically that shortened shallow can be
quite slow in the front end and the
other being that okay right and the
other is so freaking ugly I mean the
fact that we still have it looking like
this after all these years that was what
it was 30 years ago why haven't we
replaced that with that lozenge form
that's used in the too big thing Lou
that will be a question for you I
believe we can the reason we haven't I
can't answer okay can we investigate
doing that please okay but that's
separate from what you're proposing here
what are you proposing here right so so
the idea is so unlike right unlike the
output size limit or where you know you
might write you might want to know the
actual results of the computation so
that you know you're willing to wait
some for it to format even if the output
size limiter is a little can be slow in
certain situations the mere use case
here give me a case where you generate
this so this is the thing where we say
something like a log for example
transpose of range ten to seven but that
that's that's too fast to put a
semicolon at the end and see what
happens with the seven so the question
is is is that it is the message that
it's taking a long time if you acquire
that not now quiet it do the same thing
with with quiet and the semicolon super
fast so the question is why is the
message so slow why is this a design
problem it's just sounds like a bug well
yes or no there's well a it's a bug
that's you know potentially quite
difficult to fix but also the question
is well I mean the issue there is that
we're feeding it to a formatter that is
genuinely and and diligently trying to
format it even if it's going to be very
complicated to do it and arguably
if it knows the byte count is huge it
shouldn't even bother right and and and
sort of the the point is that the things
that appear in messages are generally
things that you typed in so you don't
necessarily need you know to see the
details right not sure that's true I
think many cases would be generated but
yeah what's but what are you proposing
here but instead this generates some
ionized form here right so if it's above
you know say the limit that triggers the
output size limiter then yes then we
create some sort of mechanized form
which just store stores it in a variable
right we store it just put it here as an
ionized form and because then you're
potentially you know creating these huge
notebooks which aren't obvious how huge
they are or the user can no longer
access that expression which maybe isn't
the end of the world I don't think it's
the end of the world is the thing is
huge I'd be perfectly happy to see
instead of this thing some
characterization I mean basically short
isn't doing its job very well because I
don't even know why because it's because
for some reason short is slow in this
case if short was blindingly fast in
this place in this case will we be
having this discussion or not we might
not I mean there there is all right look
let's chase that first let's chase the
question of whether there is a way
of making short fast where it punts if
it has to just for the sake of being
fast okay I know that old code I think
was originally written by me like 31
years ago or something well their vision
of short that's used in the front end is
completely different from the not really
basically because it's written in C so
basically somebody who knows the
front-end code base has to apply on this
know somebody who knows the kernel C
code base needs to a point on this and
that's basically me and Tom okay right
and so basically the way the way short
works in a front-end is it makes box it
does make boxes on the whole expression
and then it shortens the boxes that's
stupid I mean it's not stupid if you
want to avoid kinking oh wait a second
wait a second wait a second this is a
giant byte count at what point do you
discover the byte count what what do you
mean when you feed okay in a message
right which by the way doesn't have to
be the same format or as everything else
in a message it's being fed something if
the byte count of the thing it's fed is
something modest then all's good the
byte count is huge
then you probably have to do some kind
of emergency procedure right and so that
that is what we are suggesting okay so
I'm proposing that the emergency
procedure is merely a more armor-plated
version of short not a whole different
mechanism I'm just proposing that short
go in with you know full hazmat suit or
whatever if it if it does if it knows
the byte count is huge
and for example doesn't recurse very far
if it knows the bike count is huge for
example this case it will be fine if the
thing didn't recurse them to that list I
don't know okay how about how about I
really don't think this is for this
meeting I really don't think this is a
design so I don't think we want to
invent a whole new mechanism to deal
with this I think this is basically just
a robustness problem for for short and I
mean we can tackle it if you really
really really really want me involved we
can look at some code and things but I
think we try to avoid that all right
well I mean I'm not sure okay I mean
this is look the issue is you don't know
how to make short right now because you
haven't looked at the code so we don't
know whether it's even hard we don't
know how to make it want in the case
okay let me put it this way if it were
easy to fix short I would have done it
three years ago when I first became
aware of did you but you looked at the
code at that time it wasn't easy to fix
is that the basic point yes okay what's
that I wanted to point out one other
thing and that is the output size
limiter also depends on short and it
must be able to call short in a mode
that doesn't punt it needs to be able to
show something I believe yeah right
right but I mean so there's different
two different versions of short one that
happens in messages one that happens in
the output size limiter okay that's what
I'm suggesting well how about we look at
that
if we need to let's come back to that if
there's okay so all right so then yeah
that's I guess that's probably easy
enough to do right that we just have
instead instead of calling short of
shallow which is what we currently I
mean maybe we just want to change it
entirely instead of calling short of
shallow which is what we currently
do we just do or at least above a bite
certain bite UF of ARDS and right we
have a bracket that possibly with our
you know as beautifully as we can but we
basically punked above some about bites
count because it's just never gonna be
relevant right okay by the way is there
a way in here see actually there is one
thing we should consider having in this
stack here which is to actually get the
expressions out see what i'm saying how
impossible it would be to have short be
copy/paste able thing and carry around
the original we don't even want that
it's it's a if it's ten million items we
do not want that you certainly don't
want to send them to the front end right
and if you it's a question it's an open
question Stephen whether you want to
store them in the kernel if they're that
large I don't think you do so I think
you can message but the thing you just
asked for in this menu would need to go
somewhere to get those values well I
would be perfectly happy with it eyes
actual suggestion here which was to have
some variables in the kernel that store
these you know the generated message
things and perhaps you know perhaps all
that happens and maybe this is too hacky
is for the most recently generated
message there is a variable somewhere or
the most recently generated few messages
there is there a variable somewhere
internal variables that store those you
know that store links to those message
contents
this may be too much trouble you
understand what I'm suggesting it's just
so that you can extract what the actual
thing was right we're already storing
the stack and you're suggesting storing
a little bit more or possibly a lot more
yes I'm suggesting but I mean the other
possibility is which would already be
very useful is to store it if it's short
see what I'm saying not stored above
some byte count because if it's short
won't it already appear in the message
know that there's a medium ground where
you know I'm not infrequently set dollar
you know unset dollar message preprint
so I can see what the actual content of
the message was because it's a page long
or something yeah I think that there is
a an interesting case for this so I'd
like to propose that we try to look at
that okay to put in the message in that
message information menu a thing that
says essentially copy what we call it
copy message expressions mm-hmm and then
it basically becomes a list of the
message expressions okay yeah I like
this I like this quite a lot I think it
you know for that intermediate ground
provides away because right this is why
I wanted the little variable right
because I was worried about the
intermediate ground whereas if it's you
know tallies problem right where he's
creating some enormous array he's never
going to want to see that and he's the
one right this is he was the original
bug reporter because of you know being
affected by this okay sounds good
presidents forum okay this is a very
this is a rapidly moldering chestnut
isn't it well it's it's something I
think probably it's better to take a
look at the at the source page okay
because were version 1 creature yes but
we're update
it's magnificent okay and they okay
right so right we're adding the the one
argument form which right basically says
to always parentheses and the three
argument form which allows you to give
it an associativity in addition to a
precedence and running right now in the
prototype build actually I'm not sure if
it's in the prototype build it's in my
local build I don't remember if I put it
didn't so I mean this is basically if I
say a plus B here and then the
precedence level is something totally
grotesque right well it's a number
between one and 999 or possibly one in a
thousand so if I were to do something
where I were to say just for the sake of
I mean if assuming we have something
here I'm gonna just do something kind of
grotesque okay I'm gonna say nest list
precedence form random integer right I'm
just I'm just trying to test what
roughly this looks like random integer
up to a thousand right and then I'm
gonna do let's so there's no
associativity there so that's probably a
sign I don't have the new version right
that's not accepting a third argument
well that's because we haven't defeat
your eyes the the note right okay so if
I do this what on earth am I seeing here
right so that's not going to parentheses
ever because you're you're in sort of
singleton
land right your your your
comma-separated so this would be I mean
there are some examples if you some
future bison tentative examples so right
so there's that little tentative one is
what's this postfix not repeating what
is that business right so we have
operators like factorial where so
normally if you have a repeated a
repeated postfix or prefix operator you
don't add parentheses but we have some
special ones like factorial where you do
want to add parentheses because
otherwise you'll confuse them with
factorial oh gosh that's grotesque this
prac second argument you are proposing
to add a whole world of more complicated
things there is that correct well I'm
proposing to add the third argument and
then there was the right then there was
the one argument form which was to write
to basically always parenthesize what
problem we're trying to solve here
globally so we were trying to solve the
problem of making it easy to add
parentheses so that's the one argument
form and then the three argument form
was basically sort of half there so I
just sort of cleaned it up and okay
what's the relationship between that and
I mean why is precedence form so
precedents form as one argument would
just always add parens is that the idea
whenever it appears as an argument to an
operator yes okay
so and by the way this see notes for we
really have to fix those I mean that's
the documentation issue which sort of a
holdover from when the thing was a
physical book we didn't want to make too
long um okay so what you're saying is if
I say F of well if I say a plus
precedents form B comma 10 or something
right okay then I will get that and if
you've made it 900 and then you would
definitely knock in parentheses even if
they if they were potentially needed by
whatever was inside of the first
argument of precedents form ok so right
so basically so so they're they're sort
of I guess I have sort of three sets of
issues one is the documentation of in
fix talks about four types of grouping
but doesn't really make that much sense
and that's really three we really have
three types of grouping because you have
[Music]
okay well it could be clear on what
we're talking about here and the
precedence form is from version one
right in fact some version one and has
the most pathetic set of examples yes
and and basically my if you basically
[Music]
yes so in fix was never really fully
ported over to the box world so that for
argument form which is listed in the
first note doesn't work in the front end
goodness sake okay and that solvable or
is that not solvable
I suppose it's potentially solvable but
I guess my my feeling is that it's
perhaps better to to obsolete in fixed
prefix and postfix and just sort of tell
people we have format and we have you
know two boxes and you know precedence
form you know I mean the fact that that
hasn't been missed in 22 years that for
argument form is kind of telling I think
have you looked in the bug reports do
you know if people have looked for it I
don't think people have looked for it I
think people have looked so people have
complained about the fact that if you do
some funky you know operators and it may
not the output may not parse the same as
the input okay
which is probably a harder problem to
fix and whatever happened to the Jason
Harris notation package that people use
it's still there people still use it we
get bug reports about that every now and
I think this is a topic with it needs a
slightly more global view I mean I I
don't
maybe we can add those features to
precedents form that's fine I certainly
think the one argument thing is useful
um the one argument one is clearly
useful whether the look maybe what we
can do is start building out this one
with associativity being a string
argument don't try and use symbol forms
like prefix and so on there but always
just use a string argument let's try and
build out president's form in the way
that you are essentially specking it
with these different you know non
repeating whatever it is things the
different choices for the third argument
there and let's see how that works okay
and then we may also subsequently talk
about deprecating in fix prefix postfix
okay although I'm not sure we need to
but we'll
we can we can discuss that um I mean I I
don't see why we would deprecated them
actually I think we but let's get
precedents form cleaned up first
okay okay all right let's move on utf-16
ETF is this this seemed like you had it
under control right so there was one
there was one point of I think this
agreement between John and David neither
of whom could make it to this meeting
but basically the the question was what
do you do about utf-32 and utf-16 in two
character code and from character code
so one school of thought says basically
well utf-32 should basically be like
unicode right it just gives the number
and if you ask for the little endian
version then it still gives you numbers
but it gives right it basically byte
swaps the integers right so if you ask
for that I own this town
is there a little endian is their way of
asking for a little endian starts
mattering at you okay doesn't in this
matter to utf-16 yes
okay right so basically the question is
so if you ask for that in for utf-32 or
utf-16 the question is would you get one
32-bit number or would you get for 8 bit
numbers sorry for utf-16 here right so
then the question is huh that did
something I wonder what's that right so
the question is should that pretty
strongly think that should produce a
single integer okay and and that was my
and Jon's feeling as well
so only integers should packets bits
however you know the Andean this says
two packets bits yep okay so that's
that's what we'll do
okay fine I mean I think to character
code has to return an integer code okay
okay so this is rather magnificent this
stuff but I mean this is a complicated
topic I thought this was being
aggregated into the meeting that we have
about um package managers stuff which is
in like an hour but what is this this is
a so right so the question is should we
give Pacolet a summary box and B what
should that summary box be and I think
we have I mean other than the icon which
would probably need to be better I mean
they think we have something you know
pretty reasonable and how would you ever
see one of these so for example there's
the first input there where you record
install or you pack let's search I see I
see I see
right now that packets thing is some
kind of old style right yeah I
completely agree a proper summaries not
boogie better right so in which I have
no I mean I have no objection to adding
this in principle the one thing I would
point out which i think is rather weird
is that Pacolet is a non systems symbol
and an undocumented one it's sad well I
think we're supposed to be changing that
okay I mean that's that was the point
and I think even that meeting we have
coming up in an hour or so is about that
very topic okay well whatever meaning
that is I was not invited to it so I
don't know
so usually if you're gonna be discussing
iconography can you add me to I doubt
well let's put you on call I doubt we'll
get to iconography okay um okay okay so
I think that's that's where we that's
what we want to do with that but let's
make sure this item gets into that
meeting's agenda please whose p.m. in
that meeting looks like Manuel's okay
okay that looks like go through our
agenda yep
thank you all very much thanks to folks
on the livestream see you all soon 8:00